[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild Stefan jede Woche sprechen wir hier
bei Tau Deutschland unter anderem über
brutale Morde Tötungsdelikte oder andere
bluthaken das ist sozusagen unser
Berufsrisiko es geht immer um die
irgendwie um die Abgründe der Menschheit
und wie wir wissen werden
glücklicherweise viele dieser Taten
aufgeklärt und die Schuldigen zur
Verantwortung gezogen aber genuso gut
wissen wir auch dass es leider einige
Fälle gibt bei denen die Ermittler und
Angehörigen über Jahre ja sogar jrzehnte
hinweg versuchen Antworten auf offene
Fragen zu finden und dann gibt es die
Fälle bei denen die Antwort die Lösung
des Falls einem so nah vorkommt als
müsste man einfach nur die Hand
ausstrecken und zugreifen aber trotzdem
kommt es nie zur Aufklärung des Falls
okay verstehe du meinst also Fälle wo
die Indizien eigentlich ganz klar auf
einen Verdächtigen hinweisen die
Beweislast aber eben nicht ausreicht um
jemanden zu verurteilen und die Tat dann
auch offiziell aufzuklären da fiele mir
so ein Fall wie Rebecca Rusch ein meinst
du sowas ganz genau und heute geht es
hier bei Tatort Deutschland um einen
Fall der mich deshalb ein bisschen an
den Fall Rebeca Rusch erinnert denn es
geht um das verschwind von Bianca
blömcke und Bianca Blömeke ist ja wohl
einer der bekanntesten vermissten Fälle
Deutschlands je nachdem WN man groß
geworden ist eine junge Mutter
verschwindet spurlos nachdem sie sich
mit ihrem Exfreund streitet bis heute
wurde Biancas verschwinden nicht
aufgeklärt und bis heute kämpft ihre
Mutter darum dass Bianca blömike nicht
vergessen und die Umstände ihres
Verschwindens endlich aufgeklärt werden
und damit hallo und herzlich willkommen
bei Tatort Deutschland mein Name ist
imir und ich bin Stefan Netzeband hallo
zusammen schön dass ihr auch heute
wieder dabei
seid für unseren heutigen Fall reisen
wir nach Essen in nordreinwestfalen es
ist die Zeit der Jahrtausendwende Stefan
Rabs maschendarzaun der ein oder andere
erinnert sich vielleicht noch hält sich
hartnäckig an der Spitze der
Charts
[Musik]
Pierce brusenin ist der damalige 07 und
klettert mit seinem neuesten James Bond
Film die Welt ist nicht genug an die
Spitze der Kinocharts aber für einen
Mann ist die Welt nicht
[Musik]
genug ach die guten alten 2000er da
waren wir noch jung und schön in dieser
Zeit ist Bianca 19 Jahre alt ihre
rotbraunen Haare hat sie sich gerade
blond gefärbt sie trägt einen Pony auf
Fotos lächelt Bianca kess und fröhlich
in die Kamera die Freude und
Fröhlichkeit die sie ausstrahlt ist
geradezu
ansteckend seit fast zwei Jahren ist
Bianca schon mit Sven l zusammen sie
erwarten ihr erstes Kind es klingt also
wie eine kleine Bilderbuch
zwei junge Erwachsene liebestrunken und
vielleicht ein bisschen naiv ihr Glück
soll in der Geburt des ersten Kindes
Gipfeln aber der Schein trügt sven ist
nämlich gewalttätig gegenüber Bianca
tritt ihr als sie hochschwanger ist in
dem Bauch und daraufhin verlässt ihn die
19-Jährige im Dezember
1999 und zieht aus der gemeinsamen
Wohnung aus kurze Zeit später Anfang
2000 bringt Bianca ihren ersten Sohn auf
die Welt
J obwohl Sven und Bianca kein Paar mehr
sind haben die beiden weiterhin viel
Kontakt Sven sieht seinen Sohn oft er
spielt also eine große Rolle im Leben
des Kindes bianca hat aber trotzdem
Kontakt zu ihm aufrechterhalten weil sie
wollte dass Ihr Kind Kontakt zum Vater
hat weil sie selbst hat sehr drunter
gelittenen dass ihr kein ihr Vater kein
Kontakt wollte und er hat natürlich dann
auch auf das Kind aufgepasst wenn sie
bei mir geknert
hat das ist Erika Schneider biankas
Mutter im Sommer 2021 hat Sie
bildreporterin Katrin Wust ein Essen
getroffen um über Biancas verschwinden
zu sprechen ihr werdet sie im weiteren
Verlauf dieser Folge noch öfter hören im
Sommer 2000 arbeitet Bianca in Erikas
Kneipe die 19-Jährige Kellner dort wie
auch am Abend des 5 august und dieser
Abend wird das letzte Mal sein dass sich
Mutter und Tochter
sehen
durch Aussagen von Biancas Familie und
weiteren Zeugen können wir heute mehr
als 20 Jahre nach Biancas verschwinden
die Geschehnisse einigermaßen gut
rekonstruieren und zwar so Bianca lernt
während ihrer Schicht in der Kneipe
einen Mann kennen die beiden verstehen
sich auf anhie gut sie flirten sogar
miteinander und Bianca möchte mit ihrer
neuen Bekanntschaft sogar die Nacht
verbringen deshalb ruft sie ihren
Exfreund und ja Vater des Kindes also
senen an und bittet ihn auf Baby Justin
aufzupassen im Anschluss ruft Erika
Bianca und Ihre Begleitung ein Taxi Erik
verabschiedet sich mit den Worten ich
habe dich lieb und pass auf Dich auf von
ihrer Tochter Biancas letzte Worte an
ihre Mutter sind mama ich liebe
dich am nächsten Mittag beobachten
Nachbarn wie Bianca und Sven gemeinsam
mit Baby Justin in Biancas Wohnung gehen
einige Zeit später nämlich um 14:30 Uhr
klingelt Erikas Handy es ist ihre
Tochter sie ist aufgebracht und erzählt
Erik dass Sven endgültig gehen soll und
die 19-Jährige den Kontakt zu ihm
komplett abbrechen
möchte Erika führt auf der anderen
Leitung gerade ein Telefonat wimmelt
Bianca deshalb ab und sagt ihr dass sie
sie gleich zurückrufen würde aber Erika
kommt erst eine Stunde später dann dazu
wählt bianas Nummer und darauf dass
jemand abhebt doch statt Bianca geht
Sven ans Telefon erzählt Erika Bianca
sei gerade nicht zu erreichen und legt
auf über die nächsten Minuten versucht
Erika immer wieder ihre Tochter
anzurufen und immer wieder nimmt Sven ab
Bianca könne nicht ans Telefon kommen
sie sei gerade mit dem Kind beschäftigt
oder Bianca hole gerade Zigaretten beim
Kiosk und seit deshalb nicht zu
erreichen er Mutter
hedwigt Biancas Nachbarhaus um 16:30 Uhr
also knapp 2 Stunden nachdem Bianca
zuletzt mit ihrer Mutter gesprochen hat
klingelt plötzlich Sven an Hedwigs Tür
er hat Baby Justin dabei und bittet
Hedwig darum auf ihn aufzupassen Sven
erklärt ihr er und Bianca hätten Streit
und sie wollten sich in Ruhe aussprechen
aber nur kurze Zeit später kommt Sven
schon wieder zurück und holt seinen Sohn
wieder ab ganz schön konfus das ganze er
behauptet Bianca nicht mehr zu Hause
dass daran etwas verdächtig sein könnte
davon geht Hedwig erstmal nicht aus auch
nicht als sie am selben Abend in Biancas
Wohnung geht um dort zu putzen und dabei
eventuelle Spuren eines Verbrechens
entdeckt denn in der Badewanne befinden
sich Blutspuren Hedwig nimmt jedoch an
Bianca hätte ihre Tage und wischt diese
Blutspuren deshalb einfach weg wie
Hedwig später gegenüber der Polizei
berichten wird ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt
auch Sven in Biancas Wohnung er sitzt
auf dem Fensterbrett und starrt nach
draußen und er wirkt nervös immer wieder
behauptet Sven Bianka sei gerade mit
einem Auto am Haus vorbeigefahren
merkwürdig nur dass die 19-Jährige weder
ein Auto noch ein Führerschein hat um 23
Uhr versucht Erika ein letztes Mal
Bianca zu erreichen wieder nimmt Sven ab
und behauptet dieses Mal Bianca sei gar
nicht mehr nach Hause gekommen am
nächsten Morgen fährt Erika selbst in
die Wohnung ihrer Tochter um sich ein
Bild zu machen dort findet Erika Biancas
Hausschlüssel Portemonnaie und Handy nur
ihr Ausweis fehlt wo soll Bianca hin
ohne diese durchaus wichtigen Dinge und
vor allem ohne Ihr
Baby jetzt wird Erika nervös irgendwas
ist hier verkehrt auf eigene Faust
startet sie eine Suchaktion druckt Flyer
und verteilt diese in der Essener
Innenstadt nach vier Tagen erfolglos
wendet sich Erik an die Polizei und gibt
eine vermissten Anzeige auf die
Ermittler zeigen sich jedoch wenig
kooperativ und die Dame hat mich dann
aber regelrecht ausgelacht und hat
gesagt soll mich nicht so anstellen
19jährige verschwindet schon mal Gag ich
kenne do mein Kind und ist dann auch
unter auch unter Zwang sind sie dann mit
mir in bianas Wohnung
gegangen aber die polizeiliche
Durchsuchung in bian Wohnung ist
ergebnislos finden weder etwas
Verdächtiges noch etwas was auf den
Verbleib dieser 19-Jährigen Jungfrau
hinweisen könnte Stunden Tage Wochen
vergehen ohne ein einziges Lebenszeichen
von Bianca die Polizei geht aber immer
noch von einem harmlosen vermisstenf aus
und intensiviert die Ermittlung nicht
bis Hedwig zufällig Biancas Nachbarin
trifft ein Ereignis das alles
verändert diese Nachbarin ählt Biancas
Großmutter dass sie am 6 August also am
Tag des Verschwindens einen heftigen
Streit zwischen Bianca und Sven
mitbekommen habe in der Polizeiaussage
der Nachbarin steht unter anderem
folgende Aussage ich hörte einen Knall
dann rief Bianca bitte bitte nicht nein
sie rief insgesamt
dreimal gut dass die Nachbarin überhaupt
noch von ihren Beobachtung berichtet
aber warum erst jetzt seit Wochen wird
Bianca vermisst wer weiß was es
verändert hätte wenn die Nachbarin
früher etwas gesagt hätte die Aussage
der Nachbarin die Blutspur in der
Badewanne und der Fakt dass Bianca
verschwunden ist ohne irgendetwas
mitzunehmen verändert jetzt die
Situation die Ermittler gehen von einem
Tötungsdelikt aus eine Mordkommission
wird gegründet fast dre Monate nachdem
Bianca verschwunden ist und die
Ermittler Stellen schnell einen
Tatverdächtigen fest Biancas Exfreund
natürlich den Vater ihres Kindes die
Mordkommission hört Svens Handy ab und
sucht im rheinherne Kanal nach möglichen
leichenablageorten im Mai 2001 also ein
dreiviertel Jahr nach Biancas
verschwinden wird Sven festgenommen der
Vorwurf Totschlag ein Durchbruch in den
Ermittlungen aber dieser hält nicht
lange an nach seiner Aussage auf der
Polizeistation wird Sven wieder laufen
gelassen und der Fall Bianca blömike
wird zum coldcase
die Jahreszeiten wechseln Justin wird
größer und größer und Biancas
verschwinden gerät in Vergessenheit doch
für Erika steht seit diesem Augusttag im
Jahr 2000 die Zeit still
2021 nimmt die Mordkommission die
Ermittlungen erneut auf die Ermittler
überprüfen Biancas Putzutensilien auf
dnaspuren und suchen mit einem
spezialhund ein Brachgelände in Essen
nach Biancas sterblichen Überresten ab
auch das vergeblich Erika lebt
inzwischen in einer neuen Wohnung die
Wände und Schränke sind voll mit Bildern
ihrer Tochter von ihrem Balkon aus
schaut Erika auf das Haus in dem Bianca
bis zu ihrem Verschwinden gelebt hat so
fühlt sich Erika ihrer Tochter auch nach
über 20 Jahren noch nah und verbunden es
ist natürlich ganz schwer wenn wenn
Geburtstage sind oder
Hochzeiten die ich natürlich mit Ban
nicht mehr erleben kann
ich möchte Bianca nur noch
finden dass ich sie begraben kann und
das war dann auch anfangen können zu
trauern weil auch das konnten wir die
ganzen Jahre nicht weil wir immer mit
der Suche beschäftigt sind ich bin so in
so
Schwebezustand 1% sagt ja vielleicht
doch noch lebt und der andere sagt nee
unmöglich sie muss tot sein im
vergangenen Jahr schließlich lä 12
Quadrat große Plakate anfertigen und auf
der vierspurigen Gladbecker Straße in
Essen Aufhängen von dort lächelt Bianca
überlebensgroß auf die vorbeifahrenden
Autos neben ihrem Foto steht der Aufruf
Hinweise zu geben Erika hat dafür eine
Belohnung von 4000 € ausgelobt ihre
Hoffnung weil Totschlag nach 20 Jahren
verjert könnten der Täter oder auch
wichtige Zeugen jetzt vielleicht
gesprächiger sein keiner braucht heute
Angst mer haben vor ein Verurteilung
egal was passiert ist bitte sag mir wo
bianca
ist
denn ich bin bin auch nicht
mehr ja zornig oder wütend auf dich die
Zeiten sind vorbei ich möchte nur Bianca
finden damit ich und meine Familie
abschließen können mit der
Suche seit mehr als 23 Jahren fehlt von
bian lömike jede Spur Justin ihr Sohn
konnte nur 7 Monate seines Lebens mit
seiner Mutter verbringen seit mehr als
8000 Tagen wartet und hofft Erika auf
Antworten darauf was mit ihrer Tochter
geschehen ist falls du lieber Hörer
irgendwas weißt was den Ermittlern
helfen könnte wende dich bitte an das
Polizeipräsidium in Essen Nummer und
entsprechende Informationen findet ihr
in den Show Notes und damit sind wir am
Ende unserer heutigen Episode von Tatort
Deutschland angelangt falls ihr Fragen
Anregungen oder Kritik habt dann schickt
uns gerne eine Mail oder schreibt uns
bei Instagram wir freuen uns ebenso über
fallvorschläge wir freuen uns aber auch
von euch zu hören und wenn ihr uns eine
gute Bewertung hinterlasst und natürlich
auch wenn ihr diesen Podcast abonniert
zur Recherche bei diesem Fall nutzten
wir das aktepzial vermisst aus dem Jahr
2020 und natürlich unsere eigene
Berichterstattung von Bild undbild.de
wir freuen uns wenn ihr auch beim
nächsten Mal wieder mit dabei seid bis
dahin euer milco und euer Stefan
tschüss dir hat diese Folge von Tatort
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Rusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Hermann wir hören uns be t Deutschland